100e cinéma avec la sortie attendue du
dernier film d'andré dessinait les temps
changent avec les retrouvailles d'un
couple mythique catherine deneuve et
gérard depardieu catherine deneuve qui
est notre invité l'histoire d'un amour
de jeunesse d'un premier amour qui
ressurgit trente ans plus tard
marie-jo joie ils se sont aimés se sont
quittés 30 ans ou passé elle a refait sa
vie à tanger avec un médecin lui ne l'a
jamais oublié un amour obsessionnel qui
le pousse à la reconquérir
pour ne rien vous cacher je suis venu à
tanger dans l'espoir de vous deux
langues je suis pas sûr qu'on soit
d'accord lui en avait parlé
depardieu deneuve ont nourri envie de
dire ils se sont tant aimés au cinéma
sept films ensemble et pourtant disant
qu'ils ne s'étaient pas retrouvés sur un
plateau un conte évident qu andré
téchiné entraîne à nouveau dans une
histoire d'un romantisme absolu
j'en ai marre tu t'attaques russe comme
ça que j'étais par ses moyens vers la
sortie du boulot mon travail je sais pas
si vous voulez si si si au moment de
leur triomphe glamour et de leur
jeunesse je sais pas si mon réintéresser
comme comme couple met maintenant en
revanche avec justement tout le travail
et tout là toute la distance du duc
l'épreuve du temps si vous voulez je
trouve qu'ils ont tout à coup à qui une
pâte humaine une pâte humaine surtout
celle de catherine qui continue de
fasciner le cinéaste hôtel des amériques
le lieu du crime la saison préférée les
voleurs cinq fois qu'il la dirige une
rencontre qui a changé sa vie de gens
chercher
elle a eu une influence pas seulement
dans dans ma vie parce qu'une grande
fraternité en quelque sorte entre nous
si vous l'aimez mais une une influence
dans mon travail c'est à dire que avant
de là
avant de travailler avec elle j'étais un
peu trop d'objectifs par rapport aux
acteurs et il ne parle pas de la
complicité de la confiance qui contribue
sûrement à rendre et cette histoire
d'amour aussi touchante